hey everyone I'm here at Marvel Studios
with the head of visual development
Ryan miner ding hello sir whoo I wish we
could go to your office but apparently
it's full of spoilers there's a lot of
stuff on the walls that people can't see
well I have an NDA so I'm gonna find out
all the secrets after this interview
when the cameras aren't rolling but for
now let's talk about Mysterio when me
and the rest of the fans saw the trailer
we were like holy smokes that is one big
swashbuckling heroic looking Mysterio
and he has like a pretty kind of fun
campy origin story in the comics so how
do you start to play with that and
turning it into that look with his look
from the comics because it's essentially
like in some version it's more like a
green onesie yeah of it being more of a
classic superhero suit meant we were
looking at things we've done for vision
like just saying like okay how could we
translate that into something that was
reasonable for for Mysterio see now that
you've said it's a onesie all I can
wonder is if it has little buttons in
the back it doesn't it doesn't zip er
somewhere but no no buttons it's
mysterious though you know one of the
things we do just to automatically make
something feel more real in some ways
it's just making metallic I mean the
second you you use a metallic paint on
his on his suit it just feels more real
and gives life to the you know when he's
moving around there's reflections
playing off of it and it just doesn't
feel dead or flat he's got such a long
comic-book history from way back in 1964
where did you start with those original
sort of Ditko drawings and bring it into
today I mean we I always loved looking
back at the old artwork is the older it
is the better because it usually starts
from such a unique place and that's one
of the reasons why MCU characters tend
to end up looking sort of more unique
with with the Ditko stuff I mean he drew
hands so well and he also like the
weirdness of the characters really came
through whether it was in spider-man or
Mysterio over in Doctor Strange and then
also just the the main icon be in that
fishbowl
like how can we how can we get that in
there and and and have it not look goofy
an interesting question too because one
of the things
I always think about that fishbowl look
in the comics it's so cool but you're
like how does he get his head in there
you know if it is a perfectly round
sphere so how do you kind of solve for
that so we were actually trying to do
that we're seeing if early on it would
be better if we turn it into more of a
an actual head friendly shape and then
you do it it just doesn't look like
Mysterio and that's one of the things
that like when you start down these
roads of looking at what was done in the
past from the comics and seeing how to
translate it for screen there's so many
problems that are solved for us that we
don't necessarily even register so like
I tried to do other versions of the the
big fishbowl head without the cloak or a
smaller cloak and it just doesn't work
like didn't go get it right the first
time
there's so many fun little details from
the comics that always appear in the
films I'm a huge comic book reader and
fan I know our fans are as well do you
have maybe three little Easter eggs for
us that you can tell us from the
original visual design for mr. useless I
mean I think working in as many places
as we could I think we got them here on
the clasps they're gonna when he uses
his powers or sort of triangle with an
eye in it there's there's other very
subtle things that I don't know if you
would really want to see them if you but
I want to know there if you look at
something like classic superhero
costumes usually have some version of a
letter a symbol or letter oh yeah
Mysterio doesn't in the comics typically
other than the eye clasps sort of did
that a Mysterio there's a bunch of like
vertical bands around the stomach that
there are essentially M's that are
repeating I love that it's very as very
subtle and if once you see it you kind
of kind of can't unsee it so um also I
want to say that you took a bold move
and you gave Mysterio of beard
what'swhat's up with bearded Mysterio
besides the fact that Jake Gyllenhaal
looks great with a beard I think a lot
of it has to do with Jake Gyllenhaal
looking great with the beard okay I mean
in a lot of ways this movie's Peter
trying to come to terms with being his
own hero and not living under Tony's
shadow and I think having another mentor
also had a goatee it also as a symbol of
age in some ways being seasoned in the
world and I and more directly relating
it to Tony I think that connection is
great to have visually I got to view
some of your iterations of the Mysterio
entire design how many iterations do you
think you went through he's one of those
characters who can go in a lot of
different directions any any of the
characters that really have a very
unique and interesting origin visual
mean that means when you translate it to
in a story world that needs to be more
realistic it needs to be grounded in
something else so we've I don't I
probably tried between 60 and 70 I think
it took about that many to get through
for further producers and Jon to really
feel like it it was working one of the
best parts of this job is really being
able to work with amazing filmmakers and
and and turn their ideas into something
that's real based on the comic origins
of the characters Marvel Studios is
unique in you know really how much we're
able to try and translate from the
comics and how truthful we try to be to
to the uniqueness and and and the sort
of greatness of those icons and working
with the filmmakers to do that as a real
treat and you've been here since the
very beginning of Marvel Studios alright
yeah I was I was fortunate to get hired
by Jon Favreau an Iron Man one so it was
designed the mark 1 Iron Man suit which
is fun I'm just like sitting here with a
little piece of Marvel history that's
you that's you that's very kind thank
you so much for talking with us oh thank
you for having me it's been great and
you guys be sure to go see spider-man
far from home in theaters on July 2nd
[Music]